what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like we
could be getting a very special treat
tomorrow it looks like the Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania trailer could be
releasing tomorrow morning if not
extremely soon check this out if you
happen to follow the official Twitter
account for Ant-Man you might have
noticed a specific tweet that they just
put out today it came out tonight
October 23rd at 5 PM Pacific time and a
tweet said Tiny then it had a slash
through it and then it says big things
coming dot dot dot now of course here
they are referring to the trailer the
official teaser trailer for Ant-Man and
the WASP now when exactly is it coming
well most likely tomorrow morning
typically Marvel doesn't do this they
don't tease from an official account
unless the trailer is literally the very
next day or right around the corner but
here's the deal the premiere for Black
Panther wakanda ever is Wednesday we
also get a special look at Black Panther
wakanda forever Wednesday as well then a
lot of press members get to see wakanda
Forever on Thursday so it means that the
trailer is probably not coming out
Wednesday or Thursday which means it's
most likely coming out tomorrow morning
Monday or Tuesday but I doubt they would
tease this and not do something the very
next day now as far as What To Expect
While many people have actually already
seen the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania teaser trailer it was shown
at San Diego Comic-Con and it was shown
again at d23 we also have a description
of it that's gone around online of what
everybody saw and for those who are
wondering yes we are going to see Kang
sometimes Marvel Studios likes to do
teasers where they don't show their
villains however since we've already
seen a variant of King the Conqueror he
who remains in Loki we've basically
already seen the villain and I'm not
expecting them to show the exact same
trailer footage that they showed at sdcc
that's most likely just a special look
for those people the trailer is probably
going to be different but we will see
King the Conqueror hopefully tomorrow I
would keep an eye out for tomorrow
probably around 6 a.m Pacific Time
Marvel Studios typically does release
trailers in the morning however they
have been known to release some at night
sometimes but when that happens that
usually comes with some type of sporting
event or some type of award show so I am
expecting it to come in the morning it
should be coming at 6 00 a.m Pacific
time if it is tomorrow but it could be
anytime between 6 to 9 A.M so keep an
eye out for that of course I'll do a
reaction and then a breakdown on the
trailer that we're going to see fingers
crossed tomorrow in the meantime let me
know how excited you are for the trailer
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and of course
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on the breakdown
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof